[Musica]
il suono che avete appena ascoltato
ripetuto più volte è il suono di un
segnale prodotto più di un miliardo di
anni fa da un sistema di due buchi neri
distanti da noi più di un miliardo di
anni luce
questi due oggetti hanno orbitato per
milioni di anni
uno intorno all'altro si sono avvicinati
sempre di più e alla fine della loro
vita si sono fusi per formare un unico
oggetto un buco nero di massa ancora
maggiore
questo segnale generato ha viaggiato
nell'universo e il 14 settembre ha
raggiunto la terra dove è stato rilevato
per la prima volta come un'onda
gravitazionale
quindi vi parlerò oggi di questa
scoperta parlare di onde gravitazionali
significa parlare di spazio di tempo di
gravitazione di corpi celesti
dell'universo e di quegli strumenti che
nel corso dei secoli sono stati
perfezionati sempre di più per poterlo
indagare
quello che vedete qui è un passo
fondamentale nella comprensione
dell'universo quando nel 1609 galileo
con il suo cannocchiale per la prima
volta guardò il cielo questo che vedete
è l'osservazione di giove e dei suoi
satelliti
ebbene questa nuova finestra
sull'universo questo nuovo modo di
osservare l'universo rappresenta una
svolta epocale di portata non solo
scientifica ma anche sociale l'eredità
di galilei fu raccolta da isaac newton
che
per primo formula le leggi matematiche
che descrivono come i pianeti si muovono
intorno al sole
non solo ma anche che dicono come i
corpi sulla terra cadono attratti verso
il basso dalla forza gravitazionale
terrestre
tuttavia la svolta decisiva nella
comprensione dell'universo arrivo a
qualche secolo dopo nel 1904 albert
einstein pubblicò nel 1915 la sua teoria
della relatività generale
questa fu qualche tempo dopo considerata
come la nuova teoria dell'universo
una rivoluzione nella scienza che
superava definitivamente il concetto
newtoniano di spazio di tempo e di
gravitazione e vedete qui la copertina
della rivista time che in qualche modo
suggellò il peso che quest'uomo che
questo scienziato ebbe nella vita e
nella cultura del ventesimo secolo
secondo newton lo spazio è qualcosa di
rigido e i corpi si muovono al suo
interno attirati da quella forza
gravitazionale che li porta gli uni
verso gli altri
secondo einstein gru spazio non è
un'entità rigida ma sotto l'azione di
una massa viene deformato può essere
immaginato quindi come una membrana
elastica e proprio questa deformazione
questa curvatura provoca il movimento
dei corpi celesti immaginate di prendere
una massa più piccola imprimendoli una
certa velocità questa naturalmente si
porrà in rotazione attorno alla massa
più grande
quindi vedete è la geometria la nuova
geometria dello spazio che dice ai corpi
come muoversi e sono i corpi che dicono
allo spazio come curvarsi tuttavia non è
solo lo spazio ad essere influenzato
dalla distribuzione di massa anche lo
scorrere del tempo e orologi posti in
campi gravitazionali più forti battono i
secondi più lentamente
quindi si crea una nuova entità lo
spazio tempo il tempo non è più qualcosa
di assoluto ma il suo scorrere il suo
fluire dipende dalla distribuzione di
materia e questo fatto è molto presente
nella nostra vita quotidiana rende la
relatività generale
qualcosa di vicino alla nostra
quotidianità tutti noi abbiamo un
cellulare in ogni cellulare
esiste un gps il global positioning
system voi sapete che funziona tramite
una comunicazione della dell'oggetto a
terra con dei satelliti e il tempo
scorre diversamente nei satelliti e qui
sulla terra e se non venissero applicate
le correzioni della relatività generale
noi non osserveremo la grande precisione
che invece questo sistema riesce a darci
nel posizionamento degli oggetti qui
sulla terra
il grado di curvatura della struttura
spazio temporale dipende dalla
concentrazione di massa se anziché
considerare il sole noi prendessimo ad
esempio una stella di neutroni che è un
oggetto che ha una massa a circa una
volta e mezzo quella del sole ma
racchiusa in un volume molto più piccolo
un raggio circa diventi di 10 km quindi
una grande concentrazione di massa la di
formazione in questa membrana spazio
temporale sarà chiaramente molto più
profonda e ancora di più succede nel
caso di un buco nero una concentrazione
di massa ancora più grande
il campo gravitazionale intorno ad un
buco nero è così forte che qualunque
oggetto avvicinandosi sufficientemente
superando quello che si chiama orizzonte
degli eventi non sarebbe più in grado di
sottrarsi alla fortissima gravità
neanche la luce una volta entrata
all'interno dell'orizzonte degli eventi
può riuscire ad uscirne ci sono state
molte predizioni della relatività
generale i buchi neri sono una di quelle
un'altra fu fatta da einstein nel 1916
l'anno dopo la pubblicazione della
relatività generale
ed è la predizione dell'esistenza delle
onde gravitazionali
ora la membrana che abbiamo visto prima
con la massa
immaginate di far oscillare questa massa
in alto in basso di accelerarla in
questo modo si genereranno delle onde in
questa struttura spazio temporale delle
onde che si propagano viaggiando alla
velocità della luce
se anziché considerare una singola massa
consideriamo due corpi celesti che
orbitano uno intorno all'altro anche
questi produrranno delle onde di gravità
delle deformazioni delle increspature
nello spazio tempo che si allontaneranno
dalla sorgente viaggiando attraverso
l'universo
sono queste piccole increspature della
struttura spazio nei por al e che lo
scorso settembre siamo riusciti a
misurare come possiamo misurare questi
effetti per capirlo dobbiamo capire come
l'onda gravitazionale interagisce con la
materia qual è l'effetto che provoca
ora immaginate e di considerare questa
distribuzione di masse lungo degli
anelli
un'onda gravitazionale che viaggi
perpendicolarmente al piano
vedete le mosse sono coste in
oscillazione la loro distanza cambia
vengono allungate e compresse e poi
l'effetto si inverte e così via
ecco sono proprio queste oscillazioni
che noi abbiamo misurato oscillazioni
dello spazio tempo e di tutti gli
oggetti che sono in esso contenuti
queste oscillazioni sono molto piccole e
servono strumenti molto evoluti molto
precisi per poterle misurare la proposta
iniziale di misurare le onde
gravitazionali con la luce arriva negli
anni settanta dari vice era molto due
giovani a quel tempo e la proposta si
trasformò nella proposta di un vero e
proprio osservatorio l'osservatorio
laico insieme con vice kit torna laundry
per la portarono avanti da questa parte
dell'oceano
adalberto giazotto e alle briglie
proposero la costruzione di un
rivelatore analogo rivelatore virgo che
attualmente è installato presso lo
european gravitational observatory a
cascina vicino pisa
qui voglio descrivervi come funzionano
rivelatore di onde gravitazionali lo
strumento che usiamo si chiama
interferometro di mike elson e fatto di
un laser di alcuni specchi e di un
oggetto un foto rivelatore che misura la
quantità di luce che vincite sopra
allora il fascio laser raggiunge uno
specchio che separa il fascio in due
componenti che viaggiano lungo due
bracci fra loro perpendicolari
raggiungono degli specchi alla fine di
queste di questi bracci tornano indietro
si ricombinano e si sovrappongono
l'arrivo di un'onda gravitazionale
cambia come abbiamo visto la distanza
fra gli oggetti quindi cambia la
lunghezza dei bracci e in conseguenza di
queste variazioni di lunghezza noi
vediamo sul fato rivelatore
un'alternanza di luce e di buio questo è
il segno è possibile di un'interazione
con
da gravitazionale questi effetti sono
molto piccoli tuttavia il segnale che
noi abbiamo misurato e stato uno
spostamento di uno di questi specchi di
10 almeno 18 metri un numero
piccolissimo per capire quanto sia
piccola immaginiamo visualizziamo un
metro immaginiamo di dividerlo per
10.000 arriviamo al diametro di un
capello umano lo dividiamo ancora per
cento arriviamo alle dimensioni di un
batterio ancora per 10.000
e arriviamo alle dimensioni di un ato ma
questo non è sufficiente
vedete siamo a dieci alla meno 10
mancano otto ordini di grandezza
dobbiamo andare ancora su scale più
piccole significa entrare all'interno
dell'atomo raggiungere le dimensioni di
un nucleo ma ancora non basta perché le
vibrazioni che noi abbiamo misurato sono
un millesimo delle dimensioni di un
nucleo atomico qualche cosa veramente
difficile da immaginare
questi strumenti sono stati costruiti e
attualmente esiste una rete mondiale di
rivelatori interferometrici qui vedete
il rivelatore virgo vicino pisa ce ne
sono due negli stati uniti 1 nello stato
di washington nord ovest 1 in louisiana
sud est i rivelatori lago sono oggetti
molto grandi con bracci lunghi e alcuni
km 34 chilometri perché la lunghezza dei
bracci aumenta l'effetto dell'onda
gravitazionale allungare di 10 volte
significa aumentare di dieci volte
l'effetto che vogliamo misurare i
rivelatori laico e virgo operano come un
unico osservatorio è una grande
collaborazione costituita da più di
mille persone fisici ingegneri tecnici e
studenti
tutti lavorano insieme con passione con
dedizione con l'obiettivo di migliorare
sempre di più questi strumenti
qui vedete alcune immagini questo è uno
degli specchi che hanno misurato questa
oscillazione così piccola e sono degli
specchi di circa 40 centimetri di
diametro di quarzo purissimo vedete come
si lavora in ambienti estremamente
puliti per noi
turbare in nessun modo l'estrema qualità
ottica di questi oggetti che devono
essere ovviamente isolati da tutti i
disturbi sospesi con sistemi di filtri
molto sofisticati per evitare che i
disturbi sismici del terreno nascondano
completamente la piccolissima vibrazione
che vogliamo misurare sistemi ottici
molto complessi e questo che vedete qui
ad esempio è il tubo nel quale viaggia
il fascio laser questo tubo rappresenta
il sistema da vuoto più grande d'europa
lì dentro c'è il vuoto perché non
possiamo consentirci che la propagazione
dell'acer sia disturbata dagli urti con
le molecole dell'area nulla può essere
lasciato al caso
dunque questi strumenti sono stati
portati a livelli di sofisticazione e di
precisione veramente notevoli e grazie a
questo lavoro effettuato nel corso di
decenni il 14 settembre dello scorso
anno
i due rivelatori di questa rete
internazionale i due rivelatori largo
dopo aver iniziato da pochi giorni
questo run ripresa dati hanno misurato
un segnale proveniente dall'universo
vedete qui l'uscita del rivelatore
l'uscita dell'interferometro da questo
andamento piuttosto confuso ha preso
invece ad un certo punto a seguire una
forma ben definita una sinusoide che
cresce in ampiezza e cresce in frequenza
fino a raggiungere un massimo che poi si
smorza dalle simulazioni si è capito che
questa forma d'onda è stata prodotta da
due buchi neri che orbitano uno intorno
all'altro in questo movimento durato o
centinaia milioni di anni
si sono avvicinati sempre di più e
mettendo onde gravitazionali hanno perso
energia alla loro orbita si è contratta
nell'avvicinarsi hanno acquistato sempre
più velocità pensate che al momento
della fusione
questi due oggetti con una massa di
decine di volte la massa del sole si
stavano muovendo ad una velocità pari a
metà la velocità della luce e 150mila
chilometri al secondo
qualcosa veramente di enorme in questo
momento nel momento della fusione sono
stati è stato generato un grandissimo
fiotto di onde gravitazionali che come
vedete poi si è propagato nella
struttura spazio temporale ha viaggiato
nell'universo e ha raggiunto la terra
questa è una bellissima simulazione ecco
nella nel calcolo delle masse si può
vedere che dalle masse iniziali fino
alla massa dell'oggetto formato alla
fine risultavano 3 masse solari mancanti
queste tre masse solari si sono
convertite in energia energia di tipo
gravitazionale secondo quella famosa
equazione è uguale emmeciquadro scritta
dallo stesso einstein e in questi pochi
pochissimi decimi di secondo che noi
abbiamo misurato e stata emessa
un'enorme quantità di energia 50 volte
l'energia luminosa emessa da tutte le
stelle dell'universo
la distanza abbiamo detto era
grandissima più di un miliardo di anni
luce
e questo è molto importante le onde
gravitazionali e attraversano l'universo
quasi indisturbata e non interagiscono
con la materia il sole i pianeti sono
praticamente trasparenti questo fa sì
che possono arrivare da molto lontano
fino da noi e guardare lontano nello
spazio significa guardare indietro nel
tempo
noi conosciamo un universo fino ad ora
per mezzo della luce della radiazione
elettromagnetica e la radiazione cosmica
di fondo ci ha permesso di prendere
un immagine dell'universo dopo 300 mila
anni dopo il big bang è bene speriamo
che nei prossimi anni grazie al
miglioramento ulteriore di questi
strumenti
sarà possibile misurare un'analoga
radiazione tipo gravitazionale che ci
svelerà i misteri dell'universo tornando
indietro nel tempo fino a pochissimi
istanti dopo il big bang iniziale il
segnale che abbiamo visto è stato il
primo di tanti esistono sistemi binari
costituiti oltre che da buchi neri anche
da stelle di neutroni anche singole che
ruotano come dei fari emettono
radiazione elettromagnetica e radiazione
gravitazionale le stelle alla fine della
loro vita esplodono sono le supernove e
durante questa esplosione vengono emesse
onde gravitazionali onde
elettromagnetiche neutrini sono dei
fenomeni incredibili quindi
l'osservazione dell'universo che è
cominciata nel 1600 con galileo è
proseguita poi attraverso lo studio
della radiazione elettromagnetica nel
visibile nelle onde radio nelle
microonde nei raggi ics nei raggi gamma
cioè l'acquista casella mancante
l'osservazione dell'universo per mezzo
della radiazione elettromagnetica
sionale a settembre dello scorso anno
abbiamo cominciato a riempire questa
casella sarà sicuramente l'inizio è una
nuova finestra sull'universo perché
questo tipo di radiazione consente di
conoscere le caratteristiche delle
sorgenti che sono inaccessibili a
qualunque altro tipo di messaggero che
siano di elettro magnetica o neutrini e
quindi restate sintonizzati perché il
futuro anzi il passato ci riserverà
sicuramente molte altre emozioni
[Applauso]